oh people on their phones in between
yeah I don't know how they do
that not yeah I can't stand
it all right going a rage about phones I
thought that was just me phones on a set
yeah oh I can't stand phones on
a set like we are doing this now you
know we're we're here doing it now we're
never going to come back here and do
this thing again and this is going to
live on forever and you you you've left
your family and your kids and your your
house and you know to come here and do
this and then and you have to go back
and explain that this is what I was
doing you know while you know your your
your wife is picking up the kids at
school and like you know dealing with
sickness and you're call you know it's
like it has to be it better be
worth it you know right I think